and three people are dead a suspect on
the run after three separate shootings
the north las vegas police department
looking for information that may help
with those investigations joe moller
spoke to a witness live near civic
center in cheyenne with more on what we
know so far joe
these killings have people who live in
this area really concerned and curious
about what happened they all happened
within a few blocks of each other one
here on mary d just north of cheyenne
and now the search is on for whoever is
responsible
and i got a neighborhood watch that
there was a shooting monday night proved
to be a deadly one after three people
were shot and killed within hours of
each other it scares me because not only
for my own safety you know i'm here
alone a lot two of the shootings
happened near civic center in cheyenne
the other near the silver nugget we
spoke to people in the area no one
wanted to show their face on camera out
of concern for their safety right now
police have little details hear no
arguments or anything like that like it
was out of nowhere zoe and her family
live on mary d avenue she says her mom
saw someone running away after they shot
someone dead in the middle of the street
my mom saw him running but like it
happened out of nowhere like we don't we
didn't hear arguing we didn't hear like
anybody running at first like nothing
and then all of a sudden that's when we
heard the gunshot north las vegas police
were back out tuesday looking for
information neighbors have questions and
are wondering if any of these are
connected it is alarming when i'm laying
in bed and i hear
close range shooting jody says the
killings are uncommon the gunfire is not
she hopes something is done that whoever
has done this gets caught and serves a
fair punishment
and we get a little bit more patrolling
in this area
now back out here live these three
killings make five homicides total for
the past three days here in north las
vegas as of this afternoon actually
about five minutes ago when i talked to
the public information officer again
they said no arrests have been made so
they are looking for more information if
you know anything you're asked to call
the north las vegas police department
reporting live in north las vegas joe
mohler 8 news now